bisher erst vereinsbündnis Sara wagend
nicht na ja formal erstmal noch gar
keine denn hier ist vor wenigen Minuten
ein fünfseitiges Papier verteilt worden
Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht für Vernunft
und Gerechtigkeit wir kennen diesen
Untertitel ja inzwischen auch wo
explizit drin steht dass dieses Bündnis
gegründet wurde um eine neue Partei
vorzubereiten also da liegt noch einiges
an Arbeit vor den Beteiligten bis das
tatsächlich eine neue Partei wird das
heißt es könnte Anfang des kommenden
Jahr werden aber wie gesagt jede Menge
organisatorische Dinge sind zu tun und
was ja auch häufig nachgefragt wurde in
den vergangenen Tagen wie soll denn
eigentlich das Parteiprogramm Aussehen
man kennt ein paar Positionen von Sarah
Wagenknecht in dem einen und anderen
Politikfeld beispielsweise was soziale
Gerechtigkeit angeht aber auch was die
Energieversorgung in Deutschland angeht
und die Migrationspolitik aber das
reicht ja nicht um eine Partei zu
gründen sondern da muss noch ein
bisschen mehr ran und diese fünf Seiten
sind da möglicherweise der erste
Aufschlag ich habe am Kur kurz die
Überschriften überflogen da steht
wirtschaftliche Vernunft soziale
Gerechtigkeit Frieden Freiheit gegen
diese Überschriften ist generell mal
nichts zu sagen aber sie sind dann
natürlich auch mit Leben zu erfüllen m
vielleicht noch kurz vorab er hat die
Fraktion der Linken im Deutschen
Bundestag hat 38 Abgeordnete wenn Sie
zwei verliert dann ist der
Fraktionsstatus weg was heißt das für
die
Linken glaube einer reicht sogar schon
um diesen Fraktionsstatus zu verlieren
ja das wird hart das bedeutet natürlich
dass die bisherige Fraktion dann nur
noch eine parlamentarische Gruppe ist
mit deutlich weniger rechten mit
deutlich weniger finanzieller
Unterstützung sie kann keine aktuelle
Stunde mehr beantragen beispielsweise
ihre redenzeiten werden deutlich
verkürzt werden äh und wie gesagt viele
Mitarbeiterinnen werden wahrscheinlich
ihre Jobs verlieren in der dann Gruppe
wie sich das entwickelt auch das wird
sich weisen wir wissen ja dass ä
Ausschlussverfahren angekündigt worden
sind für alle die hier mitmachen wollen
bei diesem neuen Projekt von Sarah
wagenkncht aber wie gesagt wie das im
Detail dann wird ähm das wird sich erst
in den kommenden Wochen und Tagen weisen
wir sehen hier jedenfalls auf dem Podium
zwei die Mitglied dieser Fraktion noch
sind nämlich Amira Mohammed Ali bis vor
kurz und sogar noch eine der beiden
Vorsitzenden und Christian lei ebenfalls
Bundestagsabgeordneter für die Linke im
Bundestag auch er sitzt hier neben Sarah
Wagenknecht die übrigens in einem grünen
gelben Kleid hier erschienen ist ob das
schon eine fabliche Botschaft ist ist
ein bisschen schwierig zu ermitteln und
zu interpretieren äh in diesem Moment
wir werden sehen was
sich da in den kommenden Wochen tut mhm
so meine Damen und Herren sie sehen
es
wird schon geredet aber das ist noch das
Vorgeplänkel vielleicht versuchen wir
noch eine Erhard schärfer Martin
Schirdewan der Chef der Linken hat
gestern ja klar gemacht dass jeder der
einer neuen Partei Beitritt dann
natürlich auch raus muss aus der linken
und ausgeschlossen wird aber wenn es
jetzt erst nur den Verein gibt
wenn die Linken denn da nicht schon
vorher tätig
werden
das ist eine gute Frage und da bind wir
sicher gespannt was Martin schierdewan
heute Mittag um 13 Uhr in seiner
Pressekonferenz im Karl liebknechthaus
dazu sagen wird da sind wir auch auch
live dabei und hören uns das genau an
und schauen wie kritisch er die
kommenden Tage und Wochen
beobachtet ich begrüße unsere Gäste des
heutigen in die Bundespressekonferenz
und die Pressekonferenz mit SAR WAG
Mohammed Ali Bundestagsabgeordnete
ebenso Abgeordneter im Deutschen
Bundestag Christian lei der Unternehmer
Ralf suikat und der ehemalige
Geschäftsführer der Linken in NRW Lukas
schön herzlich willkommen dass Sie
unsere Gäste sind schön dass Sie hier
sind das Interesse ist groß da es eine
Live Übertragung gibt möchte ich kurz
zwei Sätze zu unserer Organisation sagen
dann nicht jeder oder jede die
Bundespressekonferenz kennt wir sind ein
Verein der unabhängig von der
Bundesregierung ist wir sind ein Verein
von Journalistinnen und Journalisten für
Journalistinnen und Journalisten und
veranstalten eben hier an dieser Stelle
Pressekonferenzen zu denen wir Gäste
einladen aus Politik Gesellschaft
Wissenschaft und dergleichen mehr so
viel dazu das sei einmal
betont wir haben ungefähr eine Stunde
Zeit deswegen kann ich noch nicht
versprechen dass alle Fragen dr kommen
wir geben unser Bestes aber wir beginnen
inhaltlich hier auf dem Podium und
zuerst steigt ein Frau Mohammed Ali und
ich übergebe das Wort an Sie bitte sehr
ja vielen herzlichen Dank te Damen und
Herren wir sind heute hier um Ihnen den
Verein bündnisarer Wagenknecht Vernunft
und Gerechtigkeit vorzustellen und vor
Ihnen sitzt der Vorstand dieses Vereins
ich bin die Vorsitzende Christian lei
ist stellvertretender Vorsitzender Lukas
schön ist unser Geschäftsführer reif
suikat ist unser Schatzmeister und SAR
Wagenknecht ist natürlich auch Mitglied
im
Vorstand dieser Verein hat das Ziel eine
neue Partei auf den Weg zu bringen und
sie alle haben das der Presse richtig
entnommen dass die Entscheidung dafür
jetzt gefallen ist heute morgen sind SAR
warnknecht Christian lei Lukas schön und
ich gemeinsam mit sieben weiteren
Abgeordneten der Linksfraktion aus der
Partei DIE LINKE ausgetreten diese
Entscheidung ist uns nicht leicht
gefallen schließlich war die Linke für
uns viele Jahre sogar Jahrzehnte die
politische Heimat gleich wohl sind wir
davon überzeugt dass das ein notwendiger
und richtiger Schritt
war lange Zeit haben wir darum gekämpft
dass der Kurs der Parteiführung der die
Linke bundespolitisch in die
Bedeutungslosigkeit geführt hat dass
dieser Kurs korrigiert wird lange Zeit
haben wir gehofft dass es für uns alle
einen Platz in der linken und auch eine
gemeinsame Zukunft geben kann auch im
Sommer als ich erklärt habe aus
politischen Gründen nicht erneut für den
Fraktionsvorsitz kandidieren zu wollen
hatte ich diese Hoffnung noch nicht ganz
aufgegeben seit der letzten Europawahl
hat die Linke eine Vielzahl von
Wahlniederlagen erlebt es hat seitens
des Parteivorstandes nie eine kritische
Auseinandersetzung mit den Gründen für
dieses wiederholte scheitern gegeben mit
der Wahl in Hessen ist die Linke aus dem
letzten Parlament eines westdeutschen
Flächenlandes geflogen und dass nicht
einmal dadurch ein Umdenken der
Parteiführung begonnen hat sondern
stattdessen weiter die Verantwortung
Sarah wagenkncht zugeschoben wurde das
hat uns gezeigt dass der Zeitpunkt jetzt
gekommen ist die Linke zu verlassen
letztlich muss man sagen entsprechen wir
mit dies Austritt auch dem Wunsch der
vielfach von Parteivorstands und
funktionärskreisen geäußert wurde dass
SAR und alle die sich mit ihren
politischen Zielen und Überzeugung
identifizieren die Linke verlassen
sollen wichtig ist uns zu betonen dass
wir ohne Groll gehen und wir nehmen
trotz aller Schwierigkeiten auch viele
gute Erinnerungen an unsere Zeit in der
lenken
mit wir sind dazu bereit bis zur
tatsächlichen Gründung der neuen Partei
in der Linksfraktion zu verbleiben und
haben haben heute auch den
entsprechenden Antrag dazu gestellt wir
wünschen uns einen geordneten Übergang
auch um Interesse und in Verantwortung
für die Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiter der
Fraktion wir sehen dass viele Menschen
unserem Land das Vertrauen in Politik
verloren haben sie fühlen sich durch
keine der bestehenden Parteien mehr
vertreten wir wollen die bestehende
Lücke im deutschen Parteiensystem
schließen und eine Partei gründen die
für wirtschaftliche Vernunft soziale
Gerechtigkeit Frieden und Freiheit ein
steht denn wir wollen nicht tatenlos
zusehen dass es immer mehr Menschen gibt
die in der Polarisierung der Politik
zwischen der unfähigen und arroganten
ampelregierung und der in Teilen
rechtsextrem AFD zerrieben werden wir
wollen nicht tatenlos zusehen dass immer
mehr Menschen sich intäuscht von der
Demokratie abwenden und gar nicht mehr
zu Wahlen hingehen wir wollen nicht
tatenlos zusehen dass die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung faktisch keine politische
Vertretung in unserem Land hat wir
gründen eine neue Partei aus
Verantwortung für unsere Gesellschaft
für die Menschen in unserem Land für
alle die nicht auf der Sonnenseite des
Lebens stehen für alle die hart arbeiten
aber von der herrschenden Politik im
Stich gelassen werden und für eine
stabile Wirtschaft wir sind davon
überzeugt dass wir erfolgreich sein
werden und wir alle bringen viel
Erfahrung mit die uns dabei helfen sei
es aus politischen zusammenhäng durch
langjähriges Engagement und
organisatorische Führungsverantwortung
oder durch fundierte Berufserfahrung in
der Privatwirtschaft ich selbst z.B war
ja nicht immer abgeordnet ich bin
Rechtsanwältin ich war vor meiner Zeit
im Bundestag 10 Jahre als
syndikosanwältin und vertragsmanagerin
in einem weltweit aktiven Unternehmen
der Autoindustrie tätig heute stellen
wir Ihnen unsere politischen Eckpunkte
vor und dafür übergebe ich an SAR
Wagenknecht
bittechön ja sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren die Nachrichten jeden Tag jeden
Tages zeigen es uns wir leben in einer
Zeit weltpolitischer Krisen es gibt
immer mehr Konflikte immer mehr Kriege
mit gefährlich
Eskalationspotenzial und ausgerechnet in
dieser Zeit hat die Bundesrepublik die
wohl schlechteste Regierung ihrer
Geschichte eine Regierung die planlos
kurzsichtig und in Teilen schlicht
inkompetent auftritt und handelt und das
verunsichert natürlich viele Menschen
viele wissen nicht mehr was sie wählen
sollen oder wählen aus Wut und
Verzweiflung rechts wir haben uns zur
Gründung einer neuen Partei entschieden
weil wir überzeugt sind so wie es
derzeit läuft darf es nicht weitergehen
denn sonst werden wir unser Land in 10
Jahren wahrscheinlich nicht wieder
erkennen wir brauchen eine Rückkehr der
Vernunft in die Politik und das gilt vor
allem auch für die
Wirtschaftspolitik Deutschland ist ein
rohstoffarmes exportstarkes Land und ein
großer Teil unseres Wohlstands hängt
daran dass wir eine sehr hohe
industrielle Wertschöpfung haben aber
wir haben uns mit den
Wirtschaftssanktionen von preiswert der
Energie abgeschnitten ohne dass es
tragfähige Alternativen gibt und bisher
hat die Ampel diese Frage keine Antwort
gegeben zusätzlich gefährdet die neue
geopolitische Blockbildung wichtige
Absatzmärkte und eine Außenpolitik des
erhobenen Zeigefingers so wie
Deutschland sie zurzeit praktiziert
isoliert uns in vielen Teilen der Welt
hinzu kommen die Probleme die die Ampel
von den Vorgängerregierungen geerbt hat
wir haben einen akuten Fachkräftemangel
aber nicht primär weil es nicht genug
junge Menschen gibt sondern weil unser
Bildungssystem immer mehr junge Menschen
ohne elementare Kenntnisse und ohne
Ausbildung ins Leben entlässt und der
die ungeregelte Zuwanderung verschärft
die Probleme an den Schulen vor allem in
den ärmeren
Wohngebieten das einzige was der Ampel
aktuell dazu einfällt ist jetzt auch
noch die Mittel radikal zu kürzen die
für die Qualifizierung von Arbeitslosen
zur Verfügung stehen darüber hinaus hat
Deutschland und auch das ist ein
längerfristiges Problem ein für ein
führendes Industrieland wirklich
blamabel eine blamabel schlechte
Infrastruktur weil seit vielen Jahren
die öffentliche Hand nicht ausreichend
investiert das Ergebnis sind marode
Brücken eine Bahn die fast nie pünktlich
ihren Zielbahnhof erreicht und schwache
digitale Netze und vieles mehr aber
statt dafür Geld einzusetzen wurden und
werden Milliarden und aber Milliarden
dafür zum Fenster hinausgeworfen die
Ergebnisse der eigenen politischen
Fehlentscheidungen mehr schlecht als
recht zu kompensieren und auszugleichen
das war so bei den lockdowns in der
coronazeit auch da haben andere Länder
deutlich klüger agiert und es ist jetzt
so bei den Folgen der energiesanktionen
und auch hier sehen wir es gibt kaum
eine Regierung in Europa oder überhaupt
in der Welt die so selbstschädigend
diese Sanktionen umsetzt wie Deutschland
das tut aus all diesen Gründen droht uns
die Abwanderung wichtiger Industrien und
ein massiver Wohlstandsverlust und wir
sind überzeugt diese Politik darf nicht
fortgesetzt werden wir müssen auch
wegkommen von einem Blinden planlosen
ökoaktivismus der das Leben der Menschen
zusätzlich verteuert aber tatsächlich
dem Klima überhaupt nicht nützt denn der
wichtigste Beitrag den ein Land wie
Deutschland zur Bekämpfung des
Klimawandels leisten könnte das wäre die
Entwicklung von
Zukunftstechnologien für eine
klimaneutrale und naturverträgliche
Wirtschaft der Zukunft aber genau
Zukunftstechnologien made in Germany
gibt es immer weniger vieles was früher
mal in Deutschland begonnen wurde wird
jetzt in China und anderen Ländern
weiterentwickelt aber wenn man möchte
dass sich das ändert wenn es wieder mehr
Zukunftstechnologie aus unserem Land
geben soll dann braucht es gute
Rahmenbedingungen für einen innovativen
Mittelstand und nicht eine Politik die
gerade kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen
das Leben immer schwerer macht und sie
vielfach auch in ihrer Existenz bedroht
also eine neue Wirtschaftspolitik eine
Wirtschaftspolitik der Vernunft und für
den Erhalt unserer wirtschaftlichen
stärken das ist unser erstes wichtiges
Ziel zweitens braucht unser Land soziale
Gerechtigkeit selbst als die Wirtschaft
in Deutschland noch brummte sind viele
Menschen mit ihrem Einkommen kaum über
den Mon
gekommen die Politik hat seit Jahren von
den fleißigen zu den oberen oberen 10000
umverteilt und deswegen ist die
Ungleichheit eben immer mehr gewachsen
der Mindestlohn den wir heute haben von
dem kann man nicht leben und trotzdem
soll er nur um 41 Cent im nächsten Jahr
ansteigen und dann wundert sich die
Politik oder wundert sich die
Gesellschaft dass das Modell Bürgergeld
plus Schwarzarbeit immer populärer wird
es ist auch ein großes Problem dass
immer weniger Arbeitsverhältnisse Tarif
gebunden sind und auch dafür hat die
Politik Weichen gestellt falsche weichen
wie wir
finden viele Menschen in Deutschland
haben Angst vor dem Alter auch deshalb
weil das Rentenniveau in Deutschland zu
den schlechtesten in Westeuropa gehört
da brauchen wir auch nur in andere
Länder zu gucken um zu sehen wie man es
besser machen kann Österreich da hat ein
langjährig Versicherter Rentner etwa 800
€ im Monat mehr zur Verfügung also mehr
sozialer Ausgleich mehr soziale
Gerechtigkeit diese Themen gehören
endlich wieder ganz oben auf die
politische Agenda drittens ist es ein
großer Fehler dass die Regierung sich
von der wichtigen Tradition der
Entspannungspolitik der Deutschland
immerhin seine Wiedervereinigung
verdankt dass Sie sich von dieser
Tradition nah zu komplett verabschiedet
hat dass sie nicht mehr primär auf
Vermittlung auf Interessenausgleich auf
Diplomatie setzt sondern bei immer mehr
Konflikt dieser Welt auf die
militärische Karte aber die Konflikte
lassen sich militärisch nicht lösen das
gilt für die Ukraine und das gilt für
den Nahen Osten und es gilt für viele
andere Teile dieser Welt und wir sind
überzeugt es braucht eine starke
politische Kraft die konsequent für
Frieden Diplomatie und
Verhandlungslösungen wirbt und die die
Vorstellung Kriege ließen sich durch
noch mehr Waffen beenden eindeutig und
deutlich ablehnt außerdem ist es un
großes Anliegen und das ist das vierte
große Thema das wir uns setzen werden es
ist unser großes Anliegen dass der
meinungskorridor in unserem Land wieder
breiter wird die Art und Weise wie bei
uns Debatten geführt werden wo jeder der
von der dominanten meinungsblase
abweicht ganz schnell diffiert und
stigmatisiert wird das ist einer
Demokratie unwürdig nach Umfragen traut
sich mittlerweile fast die Hälfte der
Bevölkerung nicht mehr außerhalb eines
geschützten Raums offen ihre Meinung zu
sagen ich finde über solche
Umfrageergebnisse sollte endlich
ernsthaft nachgedacht werden und es ist
ja auch kein Wunder dass das so ist
dieser Konformitätsdruck war in der
coronazeit extrem auch das ist bis heute
nicht aufgearbeitet worden aber es gibt
ihn eben auch in vielen anderen Debatten
die wir heute haben ob zum ukrainekrieg
oder zu anderen Themen ich habe das ja
selbst erlebt weil ich wie viele Länder
des Südens oder wie beispielsweise auch
die amerikanische randcporation für eine
Verhandlungslösung in der Ukraine werbe
wurde ich auch von vielen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die heute hier anwesend
sind immer wieder als Putina oder
prorussisch beschrieben und in diesem
Zusammenhang möchte ich auch wirklich
einen Appell an Sie richten es ist ihr
legitimes Recht uns nicht zu mögen und
andere Parteien vorzuziehen oder unsere
Positionen nicht zu teilen aber setzen
sie sich bitte sachlich mit dem
auseinander was wir vertreten und gehen
Sie nicht den billigen Weg uns Dinge zu
unterstellen die wir gar nicht vertreten
oder uns in die Nähe von zwielichtigen
Personen zu setzen oder zu bringen mit
denen wir nichts zu tun haben ich sage
das aus aktuellem Anlass also neben der
angeblichen Putin näh die uns immer
wieder unterstellt wird war letzte Woche
in einer reichweitenstarken Zeitung zu
lesen ich würde eine Staatswirtschaft
aller DDR anstreben und da kann ich nur
sagen lesen bildet also ich habe nun
wirklich in meinen Büchern relativ
ausführlich meine Vorstellungen darüber
dargestellt wie mein Ziel einer fairen
Leistungsgesellschaft mit mehr
Wettbewerb und einem starken Mittelstand
aussieht und unsere gemeinsamen
wirtschaftspolitischen Ideen finden Sie
in dem vorliegenden gründungsmanifest
was hier auch ausgeteilt wurde also
setzen Sie sich bitte mit unseren
Position so wie wir sie vertreten
auseinander und unterdrücken sie die
Versuchung zur Falschdarstellung und
auch zur Kampagne das sage ich nicht
weil ich Angst davor habe also ich
glaube die jüngere Zeit hat genügend
Beispiele hält genügend Beispiele bereit
dass Kampagnen den Adressaten eher
gestärkt als geschwächt haben aber ich
sage das weil ich finde wir sollten im
Interesse eines vernünftigen
meinungsklimas und im Interesse der
Demokratie fair miteinander umgehen
vielen dank vielen Dank bis hierhin und
wir machen auf dem Podium weiter bei
Herrn
suikat ja ist noch nicht das richtige
Mikro jetzt danke schön ja guten Tag
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
auch ich möchte Sie ganz herzlich
begrüßen ein dänisches Sprichwort sagt
der größte Schritt ist der durch die Tür
warum bin ich mit durch die Tür gegangen
ich heiße komme aus aus Karlsruhe nach
meinem Studium war ich 23 Jahre lang als
IT-Unternehmer selbstständig vor 6
Jahren habe ich die Anteile an meinem
Unternehmen verkauft und engagiere mich
seither als impatinestor für ein
faireres und zukunftsfähiges
Wirtschaftssystem was war meine
Motivation bei der Gründung hier
mitzuwirken als einer der Gründer von
texminau liegt mir das Thema soziale
Gerechtigkeit sehr
Herzen leider gab und gibt es aus der
Ampel im Moment sehr sehr wenig Impulse
für die Menschen die am wirtschaftlichen
Ende unserer Gesellschaft stehen darüber
hinaus ist die Wirtschaftspolitik der
Ampel etwas was mir ernsthaft Sorgen
bereitet grund genug den Kontakt zu
Sarah Wagenknecht zu suchen ich hatte
SAR Angeboten in einem Gespräch dass ich
meine Erfahrung als Unternehmer und auch
Mentor von Startups in dieses Projekt
mit
einbringe heute freue ich mich dass über
den Verein den wir gemeinsam gegründet
haben die Vernunft wieder mehr in die
Politik einziehen kann und dass davon
vor allem die vielen kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmer in
Deutschland profitieren
werden was ist meine Rolle im Verein als
Schatzmeister habe ich zunächst
Verantwort
für die finanziellen Belange des
Vereins mir ist besonders wichtig dass
wir sorgsam und vor allem auch effizient
mit den uns anvertrauten Geldern
umgehen Spenden sind jetzt gerade in der
Anfangsphase ganz zentrale Erfolgsfaktor
für unsere politische
Arbeit ich möchte Sie auf unsere Website
bündnis- sara-
wagenknecht.de hinweisen das die einzige
richtige Webseite auf der Sie
Informationen zu unserem Verein
finden ich freue mich auf alles was
hinter der Tür auf uns wartet
insbesondere auf die wertschätzende
Zusammenarbeit mit den Menschen die
unser Bündnis in der Zukunft auch noch
bereichern
werden vielen Dank auch dafür mit Blick
auf die Zeit und die lange Fragenliste
würde ich Sie bitten sich möglichst kurz
zu fassen dass wir möglichst vielen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Möglichkeit
geben können eine Frage zu stellen und
ich übergebe aber dennoch das Wort an
Herrn lei ja vielen Dank sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren guten Morgen auch von
mir wir treten heute aus der linken aus
und ich kann Ihnen versichern niemand
von uns hat sich diesen Schritt leicht
gemacht wir tun dies weil uns politisch
keine andere Wahl bleibt Parteien sind
kein Selbstzweck sie müssen ein Aufgabe
erfüllen unsere alte Partei hat dies
nicht mehr getan und all unsere Versuche
den Kurs zu korrigieren waren vergebens
unser Schritt hier das ist die
Konsequenz daraus der Frust im Land ist
groß die Menschen spüren dass sie die
Zeche zahlen für Krieg und für Krise sie
können buchstäblich zusehen wie ihr Geld
jeden Monat weniger wert ist wie die
Zeiten für sie härter werden sie haben
Angst um ihre Arbeitsplätze in der
Industrie die gefährdet sind durch eine
undurchdachte Wirtschafts und
Energiepolitik die Schulen auf die ihre
Kinder gehen sind für ein reiches Land
wie Deutschland oftmals in einem
unwürdigen
Zustand die Brücken sind marode Bus und
Bahn kommen selten und noch seltener
pünktlich das Land wurde kaputt gespart
inzwischen brückelt nicht nur die
Fassade die Mehrheit schaut heute mit
sorgen in die Zukunft sie haben Angst
vor niedrigen Renten sie machen sich
Sorgen um die Zukunft ihrer Kinder wir
wollen eine neue Partei auf bauen die
den Rücken gerade macht für die
arbeitenden Menschen im Land wir wollen
eine Partei aufbauen die den Rücken
gerade macht für Menschen mit niedrigem
und mittlerem Einkommen für Rentnerinnen
und Rentner für Gewerkschafter und
Betriebsräte der Punkt ist ihre Sorgen
und Fragen finden in der politischen
Debatte viel zu häufig viel zu wenig
statt immer mehr Menschen haben das
Gefühl dass sie von inkompetenten
Parteien regiert werden die sich nicht
die Bohne für Sie und Ihre Sorgen
interessieren
seit Jahren schon gehen Teile der
Bevölkerung gar nicht mehr zuur Wahl vor
allen Dingen der Teil der Bevölkerung
mit wenig Geld in meinem Wahlkreis im
Duisburger Norden sind zur letzten
Landtagswahl gerade noch
38% zur Wahl gegangen wir haben ein
demokratieprbl und die Demokraten haben
das viel zu lange liegen gelassen die
aktuellen Debatten im Bundestag wirken
da manchmal wie von einem anderen
Planeten da streitet die Ampel mit der
Union wer mehr Schuld hat am Status quo
die linke Seite fällt aus und die
Rechten saugen mit ihren Sprechblasen
die Wut in der Bevölkerung auf währen
heute Bundestagswahlen wäre die Linke
ziemlich sicher nicht mehr im Bundestag
vertreten und die Rechten würden mit
über 20% dort
einziehen das wollen und das können wir
so nicht akzeptieren und wir möchten uns
der politischen Verantwortung stellen
uns dieser Entwicklung
entgegenzustimmen auch dafür machen wir
uns auf eine neue Partei zu gründen um
eine Lehrstelle in der Demokratie zu
führen wir wissen diese Herausforderung
ist groß aber wir sind organisiert wir
vertrauen uns wir wissen was wir tun und
wir bringen Erfahrung mit wir wollen der
Gesellschaft ein neues politisches
Angebot machen wir brauchen Menschen die
in der Krise des Kapitalismus auf der
Seite der arbeitenden Bevölkerung stehen
Gewerkschafter und erfahrene Köpfe ich
sage auch klar wir werden langsam
wachsen und kontrolliert wir werden
einen Schritt nach dem anderen gehen
Sicherheit und Ruhe gehen vor schnelle
Erfolge wir sind gekommen um zu
bleiben vielen Dank und verbunden mit
der Bitte sich möglichst kurz zu fassen
übergebe ich jetzt noch das Wort an
Herrn schöen ja herzlichen Dank sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren guten Morgen
auch von meiner Seite ist mir eine große
Freude hier heute morgen auf der
Bundespressekonferenz sprechen zu dürfen
mein Name ist Lukas schön und wie Amira
Mohammed Ali eben bereits vorgestellt
hat bin ich der Anfang Oktober gewählte
Geschäftsführer unseres Vereins Bündnis
SAR Wagenknecht für Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit
auch ich habe mich vor kurzer Zeit dazu
entschieden die Linke zu verlassen und
Teil des Aufbaus einer neuen Partei zu
sein dieser Schritt ist auch mir nicht
leicht gefallen ich war 2007
Gründungsmitglied der Linken die Linke
war sehr lange meine politische Heimat
stand zuletzt als Geschäftsführer in
nordrin Westfalen in
organisationspolitischer Verantwortung
und die Entscheidung all das hinter mir
zu lassen habe ich mir aus politischen
aber wie sich denken können auch
selbstverständlich aus persönlichen
Erwägungen heraus nicht leicht gemacht
wir tun dies heute aber gemeinsam und
dabei aus innester Überzeugung wir haben
uns entschlossen den vielen Menschen in
unserem Land die das Vertrauen in die
Politik verloren haben eine Stimme zu
geben wir wollen eine
verantwortungsvolle Politik die
Wohlstand sozialen Ausgleich und Frieden
fördert unsere politischen Eckpunkte hat
sank nicht eben
vorgestellt wir werden also eine neue
Partei gründen und das ist auch aus
meiner Sicht dringend notwendig und aus
organisatorischer Sicht auch eine sehr
spannende Aufgabe eine neue Partei zu
gründen ist natürlich auch ein enormer
Kraftakt ich bin mir aber sicher dass
wir das gemeinsam schaffen werden unser
Verein trifft jetzt die Vorbereitung für
eine Parteigründung im Januar
2024 wir werden als neue Partei zu
Jahresbeginn erste Strukturen aufstellen
und in der ersten Jahreshälfte werden
wir erste Landesverbände gründen und wir
werden eine starke wahlkampfdurchführung
für das Jahr
2024 sicherstellen denn die neue Partei
wird zur Europawahl im kommenden Jahr
antreten unserem Verein geht es aber
jetzt in erster Linie darum eine
Parteigründung vorzubereiten und für
diese große Aufgabe benötigt der Verein
jetzt spenden auch dafür steht ab heute
unser internetaftritt wie unsere
Webseite
bereit ich freue mich auf die
anstehenden Aufgaben denn unser Bündnis
ist stark und für die kommenden Aufgaben
gut vorbereitet ich danke ihn für die
Aufmerksamkeit und für Nachfragen stehe
ich ihn gerne zur Verfügung dann kommen
wir zu ihren Fragen und es GT die Werte
Regel jeder hat eine Frage und die
Möglichkeit einer Nachfrage und ich bin
beginne bei dem Kollegen in der Mitte
mit der braunen Jacke genau Uli Hauk ad
hauptchat Studio ich habe eine Frage an
Sie die ist ein bisschen gefühliger Frau
Wagenknecht sie waren jetzt lange Jahre
in der links Fraktion und haben da auch
Abgeordneten Diäten bekommen
haben aber eigentlich wie vermutlich
schon länger die Gründung einer neuen
Partei vorangetrieben und jetzt haben
sie ja gerade auchi beide angekündigt
Frau Mohammed Ali und sie dass sie
weiterhin den Antrag gestellt haben in
der Linksfraktion zu bleiben warum gehen
Sie jetzt denn dann nicht aus der
Fraktion raus und lassen insofern gehen
aus dem Bundestag und lassen Nachrücker
in die Fraktion die dann ihren
Fraktionsstatus möglicherweise behalten
könnte und der gefühligere Anteil nehmen
Sie den also sie haben jetzt mehrfach um
Spenden gebeten und das hier auch als
offensichtlich als Möglichkeit zu
spenden aufzurufen
wahrgenommen ähm gehen sie denn mit
eigenem Kapital in diese Parteigründung
also nehmen Sie beispielsweise die
Gelder die Sie zuletzt als Abgeordneter
bekommen haben ähm her um die in die
Partei zu stecken oder nehmen sie das
Geld was sie für das für ihr Buch
bekommen haben um das in die
Parteigründung zu stecken und ähm Frau
Mohammed Ali noch denn im Anschluss die
kurze Frage aber schon zwei Fragen und
die Liste ist unfassbar lang deswegen
würde ich dabei belassen bitte
sehr ja also die Frage ob wir unser
Mandat zurückgeben das ist ja schon
diskutiert worden als der Bundesvorstand
im Juni beschlossen hat oder mich
aufgefordert hat damals noch mich
persönlich meine mein Mandat
zurückzugeben ich habe damals von sehr
sehr vielen Menschen Mails bekommen die
gesagt haben wenn ich also wenn Sarah
wagennech ihr Mandat zurückgibt dann
wollen sie auch ihre Stimme zurück weil
sie die Linke nicht zuletzt auch wegen
mir gewählt haben und das gilt natürlich
nicht nur für mich sondern es gilt für
eine bestimmte inhaltliche Ausrichtung
für die wir alle die wir hier sitzen
auch stehen daav dafür wurde die Linke
über viele Jahre gewählt und natürlich
in dem Maße wie diese politische
Positionierung in der Linken an den Rand
gedrängt wurde sind ja auch die
Wählerstimmen weniger geworden aber ich
finde dass viele Wähler zurecht erwarten
oder zumindest ist das die Resonanz die
ich bekomme dass diese Position im
Bundestag bleibt und wir gründen ja eine
neue Partei damit diese Position also
für wirtschaftliche Vernunft für soziale
Gerechtigkeit für Diplomatie und Frieden
für Meinungsfreiheit dass das wieder
stärker in der Politik verankert wird
inoweit ähm kann ich da ihre Frage
diesbezüglich beantworten was das eigene
Geld angeht sie können sich sicher
vorstellen dass all das was wir bisher
getan haben auch nicht ganz ohne Geld
finanzierbar war und insoweit ist das
selbstverständlich dass wir uns ja auch
mit eigenen Mitteln engagieren aber
natürlich ein Partei eine Partei
Gründung oder gar ein Europawahlkampf im
nächsten Jahr da geht es um Dimensionen
die unsere Möglichkeiten überfordern und
deswegen brauchen wir wirklich dringend
die Unterstützung von all den Menschen
die mir ja in den letzten Monaten auch
geschrieben haben dass sie sich eine
solche Partei wünschen und wir hoffen
sehr dass wir da auch eben die
entsprechenden Mittel dafür bekommen
weil wir werden nicht sicherlich von
großen Konzernen spendiert werden und
gesponsort werden das ist auch gut so
aber all diejenigen die sich wünschen
dass Vernunft in unserem Land einzieht
ob das Arbeitnehmer sind ob das auch
mittelständische kleine Unternehmer sind
ich denke sie alle könnten davon
profitieren dass sich die Politik in
Deutschland verändert und ich hoffe sehr
dass viele von denen uns auch jetzt den
Vertrauensvorschuss geben uns hier in
diesem in dieser Startphase zu
unterstützen dann bin ich bei Herrn
Jessen ja Frau W nicht wie verträgt sich
ihr ihre Erklärung sie werden so habe
ich das verstanden in der bleiben weil
unter anderem die Partei DIE LINKE der
sie das Mandat verdanken wegen ihrer
Person gewählt wurde wie verträgt sich
das mit ihrer bekannt
unterdurchschnittlichen Präsenz in
Fraktionen
Bundestag also wir wollen in der
Fraktion so lange bleiben wie es möglich
ist in dem Augenblick wo eine neue
Partei entsteht geht das ohnehin nicht
mehr wir wollen aber und ich finde das
ist die gemeinsame Verantwortung aller
Abgeordneten der Fraktion für die
Mitarbeiter ein möglichst geordneten
Übergang erreichen und deswegen ist es
unserer Ansicht nach sinnvoll die
Fraktion zunächst aufrecht zuerhalten
ich habe im Bundestag hätte gern in den
letzten Jahren in den letzten Monaten
deutlich öfter gesprochen das war leider
nicht möglich weil auch das hatte ja mit
Konflikten in der Linken zu tun dass ich
da keine redemöglichkeit mehr hatte und
ich denke schon dass es zum Mandat eines
Abgeordneten unbedingt gehört
beispielsweise auch öffentliche
Veranstaltungen wahrzunehmen durchs Land
zu reisen mit den Menschen zu sprechen
auch in den digitalen Medien präsent zu
sein und inoweit finde ich kann man mir
nicht den Vorwurf machen dass ich meine
ähm mein Mandat nicht ernst genug
genommen hätte weil all das habe ich mit
sehr viel Zeita Aufwand und in den
letzten Jahren getan und werde das
selbstverständlich auch weiterhin tun
sie waren ja oder sind wie auch ihre
Kollegin und Kollegen in der Fraktion zu
sogenannten
mandatsträgerbeiträgen verpflichtet also
Abgabe von Beiträgen äh an Partei und
Fraktion haben sie die in der bisherigen
Vergangenheit dieser
Legislaturperiode in voller Höhe
geleistet und werden Sie dies bis zu
ihrem Ausscheiden aus dieser Fraktion
tun oder nachholen soweit es nicht
geschehen ist in vollem Umfang solange
wir Mitglieder der Linken waren haben
wir selbstverständlich unsere
mandatsiger Beiträge an den
Bundesvorstand abgeführt in dem
Augenblick wo die Parteimitgliedschaft
endet ist klar dass wir unsere Mittel
natürlich dann ein neues Projekt
investieren und stecken das ist ja auch
ergibt sich ja dann komme ich zu Herrn
Kuh ich sehe nur das Mikron hier nicht
ist ja das passt vielen Dank Johannes K
von
Deutschlandfunk Frau Wagenknecht und
Herr lei vielleicht auch sie wollen ja
als neue Partei die abhängigen
beschäftigen vertreten Herr lei sie
wissen auch dass gute Jobs nicht von den
Bäumen fallen jetzt ist es so in der
Linksfraktion arbeiten gerade 108
Menschen da werden spätestens im Januar
ganz viele davon den Job verlieren oder
deutlich weniger verdienen um ihre
Familien durchzubringen das könnten sie
ja theoretisch verhindern indem sie
sagen wir geben unsere Mandate zurück
lassen Leute von der Linken nachrücken
dann besteht die Fraktion weiter sie
sehen ja gerade dass sie Öffentlichkeit
haben warum machen sie das nicht gerade
beantwortet worden so ich also weil ich
auch Herr leil
gestelltter wir wollen eine neue Partei
auf den Weg bringen und wir werden
natürlich ähm anstreben das wird ja
sicherlich auch dann die verbleibende
Gruppe der Linken abgeordnen tun aber
wir auf jeden Fall dass wir ein
gruppenstatus bekommen das heißt es
werden nicht 108 Mitarbeiter arbeitslos
werden aber s mal wir bedauern dass wir
in diese Situation gekommen sind aber
wenn die linke eine Kurs einen Kurs
verfährt der sehr wahrscheinlich dazu
führt dass sie im nächsten Bundestag
nicht vertreten ist während
dadurch eine große politische Lücke
entsteht die auch die Politik in unserem
Land natürlich verändert also wenn es
keine Kraft mehr gibt die sich für
soziale Gerechtigkeit einsetzt dann hat
das für Millionen Beschäftigte
Konsequenzen und deswegen glauben wir
dass es jetzt einfach wichtig ist diesen
Weg zu gehen und wie gesagt wir wollen
aber unser Möglichstes tun dass
zumindest der Übergang geordnet ist dass
jetzt nicht Menschen von einem Tag zum
nächsten vor dem Nichts stehen das ist
selbstverständlich
Nachfrage ja kurz kurz in Ergänzung
Abgeordnete sind ihren Gewissen
verpflichtet ich kann Ihnen versichern
wir haben uns diesen Schritt nicht
leicht gemacht wir wissen
darum die Sache ist die Linke ist eine
Polit also die Partei es ist eine Partei
sie hat politische Aufgaben auf dem Kurs
wo wir gerade sind wird es in der
Zukunft in absehbar also nach allen
zahlen die vorliegen keine Linksfraktion
er geben keine politische Vertretung
während und das hatte ich ja auch schon
eingangs gesagt die Rechten im Moment
bei über 20 % stehen auch dafür haben
wir eine Verantwortung wir haben das
abgewogen wir haben es uns nicht leicht
gemacht wir machen es nicht gerne und um
da noch einen geordneten Übergang
herzustellen haben wir uns dazu
entschlossen dass wir möglichst lange
noch Teil der Fraktion sein möchten und
würden uns darum auch bemühen Nachfrage
noch dazu eine Nachfrage an Frau
Wagenknecht weil sie jetzt sozusagen die
Verantwortung der Partei ins Spiel
gebracht haben vielleicht benennen sie
es noch mal ganz klar wer ist jetzt
dafür verantwortlich aus ihrer Sicht
dass die Fraktion aufgelöst wird und
dass diese Jobs größtenteils verloren
gehen ja ich finde es ist jetzt ziemlich
ähm also wäre irgendwie dem Anlass nicht
angebracht jetzt hier individuelle
Verantwortungen festzulegen es ist klar
verantwortlich ist die
Situation dass die Linke dass wir uns
trennen werden unseres Erachtens ist
dafür der Grund dass die Linke einfach
keine politischen keinen politischen
Zuspruch mehr hat also sag mal wenn eine
Partei die immerhin noch vor einigen
Jahren 9 bis 10% der Wählerin und Wähler
erreicht hat jetzt unter die 5% Hürde
fällt dann ist das natürlich schon ein
Ausweis dessen dass zumindest die
Ausrichtung dieser Partei bei den
Wählerinnen und Wählern nicht mehr
ankommt und um das vielleicht auch noch
zu ergänzen weil oft gesagt wird das ist
wegen der Debatte über eine neue Partei
also die Ursache
Wirkung Zusammenhänge sind andersrum
also zunächst einmal hat die Linke sehr
viele Wahlniederlagen gehabt erst dann
haben Menschen in der Linken begonnen
das waren übrigens am Anfang gar nicht
wir über eine neue Partei nachzudenken
weil sie gesagt haben so kann es ja
nicht weitergehen wir brauchen eine
politische Kraft die sich für bestimmte
Inhalte einsetzt so und jetzt ist die
Situation wie sie ist ich finde es jetzt
müßig darüber zu debattieren es ist klar
dass der Parteivorstand das anders sieht
als wir aber wir gehen jetzt getrennte
Wege und die Konsequenz dessen ist
leider dass auch die Fraktion eben dann
spätestens ab Januar
nicht mehr bestehen kan dann bin ich bei
Herrn Jung
frauncht Thema rechts ich habe bisher
noch nichts von ihn gehört zur
Abgrenzung zur AFD und der Gefahr der
AFD wird Ihre geplante Partei gemeinsame
Sache mit den mit der AFD ausschließen
gemeinsame Sache machen mit der AFD
ausschließen selbstverständlich werden
wir nicht gemeinsame Sachen mit der AFD
machen ich meine wir bringen eine Partei
an den Staat damit all die Menschen die
auch als Wut aus Verzweiflung aber eben
nicht weil sie recht sind jetzt darüber
nachdenken AFD zu wählen oder das auch
schon gemacht haben damit diese Menschen
eine seriöse Adresse haben und ich
glaube wenn Sie unsere Wortbeiträge am
Anfang gehört haben es haben sich ja
sowohl Christian Leier Amira Mohammed
Ali als auch ich in dieser Frage
positioniert ich finde aber es täte der
politischen Debatte in Deutschland gut
wenn wir mehr über eine vernünftige
Politik und weniger über die AFD reden
würden das möchte ich auch dazu sagen
ihrer Pressemitteilung beklagen sie
einen autoritären Politikstil ist aber
ein parteivorhaben namens Bündnis
sarwanknicht nicht im Kern auch
autoritär ich weiß nicht wie sie darauf
kommen also natürlich kann man sagen
wenn eine Partei die Namen einer Person
trägt dann ist das zunächst mal
natürlich stark personalisiert das ist
aber eine Übergangslösung das wird nicht
auf Dauer so sein aber
selbstverständlich wenn man eine neue
Partei startet muss sie sich zunächst
mal etablieren und äh ich bitte Sie
einfach darüber nachzudenken wie das z.B
bei den Wahlen aussehen wird es gibt
einen langen Wahlzettel bei der
Bundestagswahl wird es auf jeden Fall so
sein dass ich nur in einem Bundesland
kandidieren kann so ist das deutsche
Wahlrecht ich werde also bei 15
Bundesländern gar nicht auf dem
Wahlzettel stehen die Menschen müssen
aber identifizieren können welche Partei
das ist also und soweit haben wir uns
entschieden deswegen meineen Namen hier
mitzunehmen aber das wird keine
Dauerlösung sein dann bin ich bei dem
Kollegen von ihnen g ausgesehen auf der
linken Seite in der Mitte genau ja ja
jör Kirschner Junge Freiheit Frau
wagenknicht rechnen sie denn damit und
auch an Frau Mohammed Ali die Frage dass
sie in der Fraktion bleiben können denn
das ist ja irgendwie doch eine Zumutung
wenn diese Fraktion von ihnen gesagt
bekommt im Januar spätestens Februar ist
Schluss woll ich anfangen würde ich
gerne anfangen also wir haben jetzt
zunächst wie ich das eingangs auch sagte
den Antrag an die Fraktion gestellt dass
wir der Fraktion verbleiben ob das
gewünscht ist das entscheidet die
Fraktion in ihrer Gesamtheit da können
wir nicht vorausschauen und ich denke
dass es aber richtig wäre zu solange es
geht die Fraktion aufrecht zu erhalten
im besonderen Weise im Hinblick auf die
Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiter die dann
etwas länger eine Perspektive haben ob
das dann so kommt das können wir aber
nicht voraussehen sondern das wird die
Fraktion
entscheiden da gibt's keine Nachfrage
dazu soweit ich es sehe dann bin ich bei
Frau L und ich will vielleicht einmal
dazu sagen wir haben
noch 23 Minuten und ich habe noch 19
Fragen auf der Liste das sieht nicht so
aus würde das alles klappen Seiden sie
fassen sich alle unfassbar kurz Frau L
genau Julia l von der fazz hier vorne
genau zur Wirtschaftspolitik würde mich
interessieren sie und Herr suard setzen
sich ja für eine Vermögenssteuer und für
eine höhere Erbschaftssteuer ein jetzt
haben sie gerade intensiv betont dass
sie für den Mittelstand sind die
genauowas ja kategorisch ablehnen also
wie passt das zusammen und könnten sie
auch in der Energiepolitik mal kurz
skizzieren wie die aussehen würde also
würden Sie dann die Atomkraft nutzen
würden sie wieder russisches Gas
nutzen soll ich oder kann ich vielleicht
anfangen also zunächst mal es geht nicht
um eine Vermögenssteuer die den
Mittelstand belastet sondern es geht um
diejenigen die hunderte Millionen oder
sogar Milliarden besitzen vielfach
ererbt wir sind der Meinung dass das
wirklich mit einer Leistungsgesellschaft
nicht vereinbar ist dass ich Vermögen
immer mehr in ganz wenigen Händen
konzentriert und das ist natürlich auch
mit politischer Macht verbunden also
wenn man Milliarden besitzt wenn wenn
man sehr sehr große Mittel dirigieren
kann dann hat man auch einen
unverhältnismäßigen Einfluss auf die
Politik die Bundesrepublik war früher
ein Land in dem der Ungleichheit bei
weitem geringer war und deswegen muss
man auch darüber nachdenken wie man
steuerlich da entgegenwirken kann wie
man steuerlich hier auch Dinge setzen
kann völlig klar ist also weder das
normale Häuschen einer Mittelschicht und
natürlich hat das im Raum München oder
Stuttgart durchaus Werte von oberhalb
einer Millionen aber das werden wir
nicht besteuern weder mit der
Vermögenssteuer noch mit der
Erbschaftssteuer darum geht es überhaupt
nicht sondern es geht um die sehr sehr
großen hunderte Millionen oder
Milliarden schweren großvermögen da ist
unseres Erachtens schon ein Problem dass
vielfach Menschen mit diesen in dieser
Größenordnung weniger Steuern sogar
zahlen als mancher Arbeitnehmer wenn man
alles zusammenzählt was ihm vom Brutto
ein ommen abgezogen wird und
Energiepolitik ja wir müssen dringend
dafür sorgen dass Deutschland wieder
preiswertere Energie hat dass unser
unsere Energiepreise mindestens auf dem
Level sind wie der andere europäische
Länder oder der USA weil mit diesen
Ländern konkurrieren ja unsere
Unternehmen und ich frage mich wieso
andere Länder beispielsweise überhaupt
kein Problem damit haben russisches Öl
oder Gas zu importieren Deutschland das
übrigens auch tut aber Deutschland tut
es zurzeit auch besonders und besonders
teure und besonders umweltschädliche
Weise wir holen nämlich das Öl über
Indien und wir holen das Gas als
Flüssiggas über Belgien es wäre nah
liegender die Pipelines zu nutzen dann
wäre es nämlich sehr viel preiswerter
perspektivisch wollen wir natürlich eine
Wirtschaft die von fossilen
Energieträgern wegkommt da gibt es viele
Technologien das ist jetzt auch das was
ich vorhin sagte
Zukunftstechnologien deswegen brauchen
wir Sie um eine Wirtschaft auch wirklich
aufzustellen so dass sie eben die
Energie Bedürfnisse einer modernen
Volkswirtschaft tatsächlich erfüllen
kann das kann sie aktuell nicht allein
mit Sonne und Wind dafür scheint die zu
wenig in die Sonne zu wenig in
Deutschland und der Wind weht zu selten
oder weht nicht immer also hier braucht
es neue Technologien aber das ist
Zukunft wir brauchen jetzt preiswerte
Energie sonst verlieren wir jetzt unsere
Industrie re reif möch noch ergänzen ja
also wer die Position von mir bei Tex
minau verfolgt hat der hat immer
mitbekommen dass es mir natürlich nicht
darum geht den Mittelstand jetzt
zusätzlich zu belasten sondern wie es
Frau Wagenknecht schon ausgeführt hat
über entsprechende Freibeträge dafür zu
sorgen dass wir dort auch zu fairen
Wettbewerbsbedingungen beispielsweise
auch für den Mittelstand kommen weil wir
gerade im Wettbewerb zu den
Großkonzernen hier auch sehr unfaire
steuerliche Konstellationen haben das
heißt auch und gerade die Besteuerung
von Konzernen und das Reduzieren von
Steuersparmodellen sind ja auch
Maßnahmen die letztendlich den
Mittelstand am Ende wieder zute
kommen dann bin ich in ich bleibe in den
mittleren Block und bin bei der Kollegin
wenn ich richtig zuordne von der
SZ ja super richtig
angelikav Frau Mohammed Ali sie waren ja
sie haben jetzt wie alle anderen auf
diesem Podium betont wie warninnig
schwer sie sich diese Entscheidung
gemacht haben trotzdem waren sie ja in
herausgehobener Position für die Partei
die Leute und auch für die Fraktion
verantwortlich ähm haben sie ein
schlechtes Gewissen nein das habe ich
nicht ich habe bereits im Sommer erklärt
dass ich nicht wieder für den
Fraktionsvorsitz kandidieren möchte und
ich habe die Gründe dafür genannt es
sind politische Gründe gewesen es ist
dann ja so gewesen dass eigentlich eine
Wahl des Fraktionsvorstandes angesetzt
war aber die Parteivorsitzende nicht in
der Lage waren ein Vorschlag zu machen
wer denn da kandidiert und deswegen
hatten ditm B und ich aus Verantwortung
erklärt dass wir das erstmal
weiterführen und und meine Amtszeit
läuft jetzt aus und deswegen denke ich
war das eingeordnet Übergang möchte ich
meine Nachfrage verpulfern Frau
wagenknech gleiche Frage haben sie ein
schlechtes
Gewissen also natürlich muss man sich
immer fragen hätte man mehr tun können
in der Linken für eine andere Politik zu
werben die Frage wird offen bleiben ich
glaube ich habe nach meinen
Möglichkeiten versucht wir alle haben
nach unseren Möglichkeiten über all die
Jahre versucht wieder einen anderen Kurs
in der Linken zu verankern wir haben
haben das auch auf dem letzten Parteitag
noch einmal versucht wir sind damit
gescheitert und inoweit finde ich jetzt
ja ist es auch an der Zeit die
Konsequenz zu ziehen wenn man wirklich
sehr unterschiedliche politische
Konzepte vertritt dann ist es am Ende
besser sich zu trennen und das ist uns
ja auch von der Linken also von vielen
Funktionären nahgelegt worden also es
ist ja nicht so dass besonders geworben
wurde auch was meine Person angeht dass
wir in der Linken bleiben sondern mir
wurde ja eigentlich schon seit einem Hal
halben Jahr sehr deutlich signalisiert
also lieber heute als
morgen geh raus also und soweit glaube
ich aber das ist tatsächlich so wenn man
sehr unterschiedliches vertritt wenn man
ein ganz anderes Verständnis linker
Politik hat dann sollte man lieber
getrennte Wege gehen wir wollen eine wir
wollen auch keine linke 20 wir wollen
eine neue Partei für wirtschaftliche
Vernunft und soziale Gerechtigkeit und
ich glaube dass es dafür eben einfach
eine große gesellschaftliche Lücke gibt
und letztlich geht es darum was in
Deutschland verändert dass wir eine
andere Politik in Deutschland erreichen
das ist doch die Aufgabe und das ist das
was uns
antreibt dann bin ich bei dem Kollegen
vorne mit den dunklen Haaren genau neben
ihn ja genau ja vielen Dank Nick allipo
von euraktiv Frau Wagenknecht sie haben
gesagt dass sie bei der Europawahl dann
auch antreten werden wie müsste Ihrer
Meinung nach die EU reformiert werden
und mit wem sprechen sie dann in der
Hinsicht
bezüglich der Fraktions Zugehörigkeit im
Europaparlament also ich habe nicht noch
gar nichts dazu gesagt ob ich jetzt
antreten werde das sind Fragen die
werden wir entscheiden wenn die Partei
gegründet wird und natürlich werden wir
dann auch ein europaprogramm beschließen
und auch die Frage von
fraktionszugehörigkeiten diskutieren das
ist jetzt wirklich heute noch nicht
der Stand der Debatte ich denke wenn man
über Europa deswegen trotzdem zwei Sätze
dazu wenn man den Zustand von Europa
heute sieht dann ist er natürlich ein
relativ trauriger und äh der hat auch
wirtschaftlich auch für Deutschland
natürlich sehr negative Konsequenzen
weil man einfach Europa wird zerrieben
wenn Europa sich nicht stärker zu einer
eigenständigen Politik entschließt einer
souveränen Politik auch gegenüber den
Vereinigten Staaten wird es zwis in
dieser Konfrontation Konfrontation USA
China zerrieben das heißt wir wollen
schon dass Europa miteinander kooperiert
dass wir auch gemeinsam auch
wirtschaftlich zusammenarbeiten aber wir
sind nicht der Meinung dass das kann ich
schon sagen dass immer mehr
Machtbefugnisse an die EU-Kommission
verlagert werden sollen die
EU-Kommission ist nah an den
konzernlobbyisten und sehr weit weg von
den Bürgern und wir wünschen uns
natürlich dass im Interesse der
Demokratie auch wieder mehr in den
einzelnen Ländern entschieden wird das
wird am Ende unseres achtens der
Zusammenarbeit in Europa sogar gut tun
und auch wirklich eine neue Idee von
Europa also nicht machtzentralisierung
und Brüssel sondern eher ein
Zusammenwachsen über z.B
Schnellverbindungen mit Zügen über
wirtschaftliche Projekte die erfolgreich
sind auch über Austausch Studierende und
Schüler die eben nicht mehr daran hängen
dass die Eltern das bezahlen können das
ist ein Europa das wirklich
zusammenwächst das Brüsseler Europa hat
eher die Konsequenz dass sich viele
Menschen ja davon auch abwenden in
vielen Ländern wo dann rechte Parteien
stärker werden vielen Dank dann bleibe
ich vorne Wechsel auf die andere Seite
und bin bei der Kollegin genau ja Andrea
Maurer von ZDF
Frau Wagenknecht mich würde
interessieren ob sie planen in allen
drei ostdeutschen Bundesländern
anzutreten im nächsten Jahr mit ihrer
neuen Partei und dann würde mich noch
eine außenpolitische Position
interessieren also ihre Position zum
nostkonflikt und zur Position der
Bundesregierung dass Israels Sicherheit
deutsche staatsreson
ist also wir streben an in den drei
Bundesländern zu kandidieren aber ob wir
es wirklich in allen dreien schaffen
wird natürlich davon abhängen wie sind
die Landesverbände bis dahin aufgestellt
welche Kandidaten haben wir vor Ort also
das muss am Ende die Partei wenn sie
gegründet ist und wenn man sie in der
ersten Phase sind entscheiden aber
selbstverständlich erwarten die Menschen
das verstehe ich ja auch dass wir nicht
nur zur Europawahl antreten sondern dass
wir gerade da wo es ja dann auch
wirklich darum geht konkret für Sie
Politik zu machen in den einzelnen
Bundesländern dass wir dort auch präsent
sind also diese Erwartungshaltung wird
mir auch sehr stark gespiegelt wenn ich
wenn ich so meine Mails sehe die ich
bekomme also wir sind uns da schon der
Verantwortung bewusst aber endgültig
entscheiden können wir das erst wenn die
Partei da ist und wenn wir wissen wie
wir aufgestellt sind was in ostkonflikt
angeht also zum einen selbstverständlich
hat Israel das Recht gegen diese
brutalen Angriffe der Hamas sich zu
verteidigen das ist
ich glaube dass kein irgendwie Vernunft
gegabter Mensch kann das anders sehen
zugleich muss man natürlich sagen auch
der ostkonflikt ich habe es am Anfang
schon gesagt ist ein Konflikt den man
militärisch nicht wird lösen können und
auch dieser Konflikt hat natürlich eine
Vorgeschichte Gaza ist ein
freiluftgefängnis seit vielen Jahren und
ich glaube dass es wirklich wichtig ist
dass auch die Interessen der
Palästinenser angemessen berücksichtigt
werden wenn in der Region Frieden
einkehren soll und ich mache mir schon
Sorgen dass jetzt dieser Konflikt immer
stärker eskaliert ich hoffe dass da doch
vielleicht eher das ja das bedachtsamere
Handeln Oberhand gewinnt ich meine ich
sehe dass selbst auch der amerikanische
Präsident Joe Biden ja auch sich
entsprechend geäußert hat dass jetzt
eine Bodenoffensive durchaus zu
Eskalation führen kann die auch sehr
sehr stark die Zivilbevölkerung dort
belasten und ich hoffe dass es einen
anderen Weg gibt aber letztlich ist auch
der naoskonflikt eben wieder ein
Beispiel dafür dass mehr Waffen und
militärische Aktionen eben die en
Konflikte nicht befrieden sondern im
Gegenteil die Gefahr besteht dass sehr
sehr viele Menschen sterben und dass am
Ende ja der ganze nah Osten ein
Pulverfass werden könnte ich bleibe auf
dieser Seite und wechsle in die
vorletzte Reihe zu Frau
dankbar danke schön Christine dankbar
Frankfurter Rundschau eine Frage Herr le
sie hatten gesagt dass die Bewegung
sollle langsam und kontrolliert wachsen
wie ist das wie soll es konkret
umgesetzt werden und gleich meine
Nachfrage hinterher an alle die ein
Bundestagsmandat besitzen und in der
Fraktion ja weiterarbeiten ja doch nicht
aber Mitglied bleiben werden werden sie
denn Fraktionssitzungen besuchen wie
sieht das konkret aus im zweiten Teil
beantworte
ich die erste Frage war
ach entschuldigung ich bin ich sie ihre
Frage bitte wiederen
entschuldigung das mikr die Kontrolle
wie soll das also die Bewegung s langsam
und kontrolliert wachsen wie wird das
dan
sichergestellt als Verein werden wir gar
nicht über Mitglieder reden das heißt
wir wollen jetzt mit dem Verein keine
Mitglieder sammeln das wäre auch Quatsch
das wäre Unfug wir bereiten mit dem
Verein die Partei vor wir sammeln
Spenden denn seriöse Politik braucht
Geld das ist nun mal die Wahrheit wir
werden uns vorbereiten dass diese Partei
gegründet wird wenn dann die Partei
gegründet wird werden wir die Details
die werden wir alle noch vorstellen aber
wir werden dort kontrolliert wachsen das
heißt wir wissen um die Probleme die
eine Partei Neugründung mit sich bringt
dass dort natürlich auch
äh
Glücksritter Karrieristen vielleicht
auch Menschen mit politischen Ansichten
die man nicht dabei haben möchte dass
sie sich aufmachen und da werden wir ein
genaues Auge drauf haben dass das nicht
passiert wir wollen hier kontrolliert
ein kontrolliertes Wachstum und werden
zu gegebener Zeit hier auch unsere
Modelle dann
vorstellen genau und zu dem zweiten zu
der zweiten Frage würde ich gerne
antworten was mit Fraktionssitzung etc
ist nun ich denke das ist etwas was man
gemeinsam sollte die Fraktion den noch
bestehen das wird ja dann auf der
nächsten Fraktionssitzung
entschieden werden dass man das
Besprechen muss und wir sind da haben
der große Offenheit das auf eine Art und
Weise zu gestalten dass man da auf
praktischer Ebene gut miteinander klar
kommt wie das ganz konkret aussieht das
äh muss gemeinsam entschieden werden
vielleicht eine Ergänzung noch also es
wir freuen uns ja sehr auch über den
großen Zuspruch also schon jetzt schon
selbst bevor wir die Entscheidung
verkündet haben haben ja ganz viele
Leute mir geschrieben wollten schon
irgendwie die auf die eintrittsformulare
haben und es wird ja auch bei dem Verein
eine Möglichkeit geben sich auf der
Webseite zumindest zu registrieren dass
man also informiert bleiben möchte und
wir können denke ich sehr deutlich sagen
also jeder der unser Programm teilt und
der uns konstruktiv unterstützen möchte
der wird natürlich auch die Möglichkeit
zu bekommen aber wir müssen eben sehen
das ist völlig klar Parteien junge
Parteien haben eben ein großes Risiko
dass sie auch Menschen anziehen die die
Parteiarbeit nicht wirklich unterstützen
sondern eher vor Ort Schwierigkeiten und
Chaos verbreiten oder eben auch dass
Menschen in diese Partei kommen wollen
die vielleicht gar nicht unser Programm
teilen sondern einfach nur ein Podium
suchen und deswegen müssen wir da was
die Vollmitgliedschaft angeht wirklich
sehr kontrolliert äh wachsen weil ja wir
machen uns ja nichts vor sie werden auch
genau hingucken wer bei uns so mitmacht
und da werden wir eben ein Auge drauf
haben dass das auch nicht die falschen
Leute sind dann wechsle ich die Seite
bin auf der von ihnen ausgesehenen
rechten Seite ungefähr in der Mitte sehe
ich das Mikro wieder nicht Kollege
hinterher sabelberg ich weiß ja genau
sie sie haben sich jetzt umgedreht
dunkles Hemd ja
genau hallo Sebastian h von ntvde heute
Abend ist schon Veranstaltung von Frau
nastit in Hamburg sie halten wor ist das
jetzt der auftragt zu einer Art kerfahrt
durch die Linke Landesverbände ist das
jetzt ihr Ziel systematisch vor allem
erstmal bei der eigenen Partei
Mitglieder Interessenten Unterstützer
anzuwerärmen hat er gesagt kfah also es
wird nicht alleine also es kommen
natürlich jetzt aus der linken auch
Anfragen wo Menschen sagen wir wollen
jetzt bei euch mitmachen so das ist ja
auch völlig klar es sind auch viele die
sich jetzt das noch überlegen wir sagen
ja auch nicht da die Partei noch nicht
gibt also ist ja jetzt auch noch eine
Phase offen also erst im Januar können
wir Menschen dafür werben dann auch bei
uns einzutreten aber es geht nicht nur
darum diejenigen zu gewinnen die bisher
in der Linken sind und jetzt unzufrieden
sind sondern es ist jetzt schon so dass
Menschen die beispielsweise bis vor
kurzem in der SPD waren die bei den
Grünen
zumindest vor einigen Jahren noch bei
den Grünen sich engagiert haben sehr
unzufrieden sind auch mit der
Außenpolitik es gibt sogar welche die
mir schreiben die vorher mindestens
Wähler von CDU FDP waren vielleicht auch
hier und da jemanden der tatsächlich
auch mitgliedsmäßig sich in anderen
Parteien engagiert hat also eben z.B
auch bei der CSU habe ich auch schon
Anfragen bekommen möchte ich schon
deutlich sagen also shr verständlich
sind diese Menschen willkommen also wir
wollen schon eine große Breite und ich
finde es gut wenn Menschen die auch
jetzt beispielsweise die die Amte
gewählt haben und die jetzt zutiefst
enttäuscht sind wenn die jetzt
auf unser Projekt Hofnung setzen wenn
Sie uns unterstützen wollen also das ist
keine reine Veranstaltung jetzt für
Menschen aus der linken aber
selbverständlich freuen wir uns auch da
über jeden der konstruktiv uns
unterstützen möchte und wenn diese
Parteigründung erfolgreich sein wird
wird die BSW dann der letzte sagnagel
für die Linke sein die Linke ist nicht
unser politischer Gegner DIE LINKE wird
sich jetzt eigenständig aufstellen
und ja da kann man ja Erfolg wünschen
aber das ist nicht das ist nicht die
Debatte die wir führen werden wir
kümmern uns jetzt darum dass unser unser
Projekt erfolgreich ist und die LINKE
wird sich um sich selbst kümmern ich
kann nur noch mal sagen ich habe noch 13
Fragen auf der Liste die werden wir
nicht alle schaffen die Zeit ist schon
sehr fortgeschritten aber jetzt ist der
Kollege mit dem Laptop auf der von ihnen
ausgesehenen linken Seite dran und da
sehe ich wieder das Mikro nicht genau ja
n von web.de mich würde interessieren
Fachkräftemangel da haben sie gesprochen
Gründe wegen schlechter Bildung wie
sieht's denn aus mit Zuwanderung und
genau auch noch vielleicht wegen
unge regelter Zuwanderung wollen sie da
eine
Obergrenze also ich finde man darf die
zwei Themen nicht vermischen also was
wir zurzeit an Zuwanderung haben läuft
ja überwiegend unter dem Label Asylrecht
hat aber in zu großen Teil mit Asyl
Anspruch wenig zu tun und ich finde dass
diese unkontrollierte Zuwanderung da
sind wir auch einer Meinung auf jeden
Fall gestoppt werden muss weil sie unser
Land völlig überfordert sie überfordert
die Kommunen sie erfordert die Städte
und Gemeinden wir haben in Deutschland
aktuell einen Mangel von 700.000
Wohnungen die fehlen wir haben wir haben
10 000 Lehrer und kitaitaplätze zu wenig
in einer solchen Situation auch noch
eine enorme Zuwanderung zuzulassen ist
unverantwortlich und wir finden dass das
Asylrecht selbstverständlich gelten muss
wer zu Hause in seiner Heimat politisch
verfolgt wird der muss in Deutschland
Anspruch haben auf Schutz aber Migration
ist nicht die Lösung für das Problem der
Armut auf dieser Welt und hier müssen
wir schon auch über Anreizstrukturen
reden es gibt europäische Länder z.B
Dänemark die hier andere Regeln gefunden
haben die auch dadurch sehr stark die
Migration reduziert haben besser wäre es
noch wenn es europäische Regeln gäbe
beispielsweise Asylverfahren an den
Außengrenzen so wie das jetzt angedacht
ist aber selbst wenn die europäischen
Regeln nicht kommen was ja nicht nur in
der der Bundesregierung liegt gibt es
Möglichkeiten auf nationaler Ebene
dieses Problem zu lösen und die
Zuwanderung bezogen auf Fachkräfte die
haben wir ja überwiegend auch durch die
Arbeitnehmerfreizügigkeit im
europäischen Raum das ist ja etwas ganz
anderes aber auch hier finde ich muss
man wirklich immer wieder betonen es
kann doch nicht sein dass mittlerweile
über 2 Millionen junge Menschen keine
Ausbildung haben in Deutschland es kann
doch nicht sein dass die Regierung die
Mittel für die qualif zierung von
Arbeitslosen weitgehend streicht und
dann wird gesagt wir brauchen aber jetzt
ganz viel Zuwanderung weil wir haben
einen Fachkräftemangel also wir müssen
doch erstmal gucken dass die Menschen
die hier leben vielfach sind das ja auch
junge Menschen aus Einwanderer Familien
aber dass wir die Menschen die hier sind
die hier leben die hier geboren sind
dass wir die so qualifizieren dass sie
auch eine Chance für ihr Leben haben
also es geht ja nicht nur es geht auch
darum dass die Firmen Fachkräfte finden
aber es geht ja auch darum dass junge
Menschen eine Perspektive haben und
Deutschland ist eines der Länder wo
gerade die Frage des Elternhauses viel
mehr über die Chancen der Kinder aussagt
als in vielen anderen Ländern also wer
Arme Eltern hat ist sehr wahrscheinlich
selber arm weil er schon mal von vor
rein schlechte Bildung hat ich finde das
darf auf keinen Fall so bleiben ich
würde sagen wenn Sie sich auf eine Frage
beschränken und vielleicht die Antworten
kurz fassen dann würde ich sagen
schaffen wir noch vier Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mit einer leichten sozusagen
zeitlichen Überzug herr Steiner und dann
Herr
Tiede ja vielen Dank guten Morgen Frau
wkncht ich würde es ganz gerne verstehen
bei dem was sie eben gesagt haben zum
Thema Europa auf der einen Seite
wünschten sie sich eine europäische
Lösung auf der anderen Seite haben Sie
an dem Papier geschrieben dass sie sich
ein Europa der souveränen Demokratien
wünschen ich verstehe das noch nicht so
richtig wollen sie eine Reform der
EU-Verträge oder was streben sie an
streben sie an über die Europawahl dort
entsprechend Einfluss nehmen zu können
wäre gutes verstehen zu
können ich möchte eine gute europäische
Kooperation und die Kooperation läuft
über die Regierungen der Länder und
nicht über die EU-Kommission also wir
sehen noch dass das was von der
EU-Kommission kommt vielfach in Europa
wenig Akzeptanz genießt vielfach auch
wirklich für die einzelnen Länder sehr
negativ ist auch für die Wirtschaft also
auch viele Regeln die aus Europa kommen
da schlagen die Unternehmen auch hier in
Deutschland die Hände über den Kopf
zusammen weil es ihnen nur das Leben
schwer macht also wir brauchen nicht
mehr Macht für die Brüsseler Kommission
sondern wir brauchen eine Koordination
in Europa zwischen den Regierungen wir
brauchen z.B auch endlich wieder eine
engere Zusammenarbeit zwischen
Deutschland und Frankreich ich meine
dieses Tandem war früher mal Impulsgeber
für ganz Europa das ist ziemlich
auseinandergefallen vor allem jetzt auch
in der in der ampelzeit das halte ich
für ein großes Problem wir sollten hier
für eine engere Kooperation werben auch
für eine wirtschaftliche auch für die
Länder die dort freiwillig mitmachen
aber nicht ein Europa das zentralisiert
ist das weit weg von den Bürgern ist
also ich finde das ist doch gar nicht
schwer zu
verstehen Europaparlament kandidieren
ich habe überhaupt noch nicht gesagt
wofür ich kandidiere oder wofür ich
nicht kandidiere wir werden als Partei
selbstverständlich für das
Europaparlament kandidieren aber man
muss ja nicht deswegen für eine
Zentralisierung von Machtbefugnissen in
Brüssel sein wenn man bei der europaahl
Antritt also das finde ich jetzt eine
etwas merkwürdige Interpretation man
kann ja auch für ein Europa der der
fairen Zusammenarbeit sein für ein
Europa in dem vor allem auch die
Bevölkerung zusammenwächst weil es
einfach mehr Verbindungen zwischen den
Ländern gibt ich habe ja vorhin gesagt
meine das erasmusprogramm das ist sehr
stark davon abhängig was Eltern bezahlen
warum machen wir nicht ein Schüler und
Studenten Austausch der tatsächlich so
finanziert wird dass er nicht nur für
die Wohlhabenden zur Verfügung steht so
wächst doch Europa zusammen wir müssen
über Spracherwerb reden sprachkitas hat
gerade die Regierung jetzt auch nicht
sich gerade mit Ruh bekleckert also all
solche Dinge und zwar öffentliche also
nicht für die die nur viel Geld haben
also das sind doch Dinge die Europa
zusammenbringen und nicht
dass man einer Kommission die wirklich
nicht im Interesse der Europäerinnen und
Europäer agiert immer mehr Macht gibt
dann Herr Tiede Frau WKN nicht sie haben
gerade gesagt Gasa ist ein
freiluftgefängnis mit der Bitte um eine
kurze Antwort auch für die Kollegen wer
ist denn da der
gefängniswerter ja ich meine wenn man
sich die Situation in Gaze anguckt die
Menschen können nicht raus konnten auch
überall die Jahre nicht raus und es ist
eine angespannte Situation die natürlich
nicht auf Dauer aufrecht zuerhalten ist
und meine feste Überzeugung ist es gibt
nur eine Lösung das ist die zwei
staatenlösung und die Würde beiden
Ländern am die friedlich also eine
friedliche ein friedliches Nebeneinander
Leben ermöglichen und ich bedauere dass
das bei der jetzigen israelischen
Regierung zunächst einmal nicht
unterstützt wird es gibt ja in Israel
viele Stimmen die dafür werben meine
auch diese Formulierung die es wird ja
von vielen Menschen in Israel durchaus
so verwandt das ist ja nicht etwas was
wir nur so sagen sondern die Sorge
darüber dass sich dort ein Konflikt
zusammenballt der irgendwann massiv
eskalieren wird den haben ja viele
Menschen in Israel auch viele Politiker
in Israel durchaus geäußert und auch
jetzt gibt es ja sehr sehr nachdenkliche
Stimmen gerade auch von Jüdin und Juden
die sagen wir müssen jetzt gucken dass
dieser Konflikt nicht militärisch
eskaliert und wir müssen versuchen dass
nicht mehr Menschen sterben und das ist
glaube ich die Aufgabe der Stunde dann
bin ich bei dem
[Musik]
Kollegen weil den puding müssen wir doch
noch an die Wand kriegen also wenn sie
von einem freiluftgefängnis sprechen
dann müssen sie doch sagen können wer
der werter ist wer sperrt wen ein und
sie haben eben die israelische Regierung
genannt habe ich Sie richtig verstanden
dass wir sie der gefängniswerter der das
freiluftgefängnis Gasa wie Sie es nennen
die israelische Regierung ist also sie
können jetzt Zeh mal versuchen mir etwas
in den Mund zu legen was ich so nicht
gesagt habe aber wenn Menschen in einer
Region leben aus der sie nicht raus
können wo sie kaum wirtschaftliche
Beziehungen haben wo sie davon abhängig
sind dass sie alimentiert werden also
das ist ja dort so die Arbeitslosigkeit
ist riesig hoch der gaserstreifen kann
sich wirtschaftlich selbst gar nicht
erhalten er hängt davon ab dass er immer
wieder Hilfslieferung bekommt dann ist
das eine unerträgliche Situation und das
in dieser Situation ausgerechnet eine
terrormiliz wie die Hamas stark wird ist
tragisch und ist natürlich überhaupt
eine Tragödie weil eine solche Miliz
natürlich alles nur noch schlimmer macht
und die barbarischen Übergriffe das sage
ich auch noch mal deutlich auf Israel
die verurteile ich zutiefst also das ist
ein riesiges Verbrechen gewesen aber
trotzdem muss man doch sehen wie man
jetzt die Situation entspannt und man
wird die Situation nicht mit
militärischen Maßnahmen entspannen
darüber da bin ich mE davon bin ich
überzeugt so dann bin ich in der Mitte
noch bei dem Kollegen mit der Brille und
zum Abschluss Herr Pausch jetzt sehe ich
hier das Mikro wieder nicht das ist es
nicht das müsste es sein ähm ich hab sch
vom Stern ich habe eine Frage an Herrn
schön äh Herr schön nach unseren
Information hat ihr früherer
Landesverband Strafanzeige gegen sie
gestellt er wirft ihn vor kurz vor ihrem
Ausscheiden unbefugt einen Datensatz mit
den Daten aller Mitglieder erstellt zu
haben was sagen sie zu diesen
Vorwürfen danke schön für die Frage zu
den Vorwürfen kann ich aktuell nichts
sagen ist es noch mich hat noch nichts
erreicht in der Angelegenheit und
insofern muss ich mal gucken was da
überhaupt kommt eine Nachfrage bitte ähm
haben sie kurz vor ihrem Ausscheiden als
Landesgeschäftsführer einen Datensatz
mit den Daten aller Mitglieder erstellt
und wenn ja mit welchem Ziel definitiv
nein ich hatte dementsprechend auch Kean
Ziel und dann zum Abschluss Herr Pausch
das müsste
ja sie sagten wir haben die schlechteste
Regierung überhaupt mit Blick auf den
Konflikt im Nahen Osten was macht die
Regierung aus ihrer Sicht dort gerade
falsch könen Sie hier vorne no ein
bisschen leise sein das ist also die
schlechteste Regierung der
bundesdeutschen Geschichte das bezieht
sich natürlich auf den Gesamtauftritt
ich natürlich haben wir hat Deutschland
in Bezug auf den nostkonflikt eine
andere Situation als andere Länder
deswegen ist es nachvollziehbar dass die
Bundesregierung hier anders agiert als
es andere Regierungen tun trotzdem finde
ich auch hier auch Deutschland hat eine
Mitverantwortung dass der Konflikt nicht
eskaliert und deswegen würde ich mir
schon wünschen dass auch stärker darauf
geachtet würde ja zu versuchen zu
vermitteln das ist ja bei vielen
Konflikten dieser Welt früher war die
Bundesregierung waren die Außenminister
der Bundesregierung sehr stark darauf
orientiert eine vermittelnde Rolle
wahrzunehmen also sich nicht auf eine
Seite zu stellen sondern zu versuchen
Konflikte auszugleichen und ich finde
das ist eine gute Lehre die wir aus der
deutschen Geschichte gezogen haben dass
wir eben nicht auf militärische Lösungen
setzen die Bundesregierung hat als
erstes darüber diskutiert Waffen zu
liefern und äh die ganze Problematik des
Konflikts meines Erachtens so nicht
adressiert wie es gut gewesen wäre wie
gesagt immer vorbehaltlich dessen dass
Deutschland hier schon in einer anderen
Position ist also das sehe ich auch also
das ist selbstverständlich
so dann danke ich für ihr aller kommen
und bitte um Verständnis von denjenigen
die ihre Frage nicht mehr stellen
könnten ich beende die Pressekonferenz
und Wünsche ihn auch einen schönen
Tag die Pressekonferenz mit Sarah
Wagenknecht und ihren
Mitstreiterinnen hier in der
Bundespressekonferenz an diesem Montag
in Berlin und da sind viele Fragen offen
geblieben und auf die eine oder andere
hat es dann doch noch eine Antwort
gegeben aber die Diskussionen werden
jetzt in der Regel erstmal beginnen
schauen wir erstmal darauf was wir
tatsächlich haben also wir wissen dass
diese Partei um Sara Wagenknecht wie
auch immer sie heißen mag frühestens im
Januar gegründet werden wird das heißt
dann wird man beginnen mit den
Landesverbänden dann wird man beginnen
mit listenaufstellungen und dann stellt
sich schon die Frage ob das alles so
gelingen kann wie Sarah Wagenknecht das
hier geschildert hat dass sie nämlich
bei der Europawahl vielleicht und bei
den Landtagswahlen später im Herbst
tatsächlich mit dieser neuen Partei
schon am Start sein will das ist mal das
eine organisatorische nicht ganz
unwichtig aber und das andere auch in
gewisser Weise organisatorisch
mindestens neun oder zehn Abgeordnete
der jetzigen Linksfraktion haben die
Partei bereits verlassen wollen aber
Mitglied dieser Fraktion bleiben um
diesen Fraktionsstatus zu erhalten das
heißt man habe einen entsprechenden
Antrag gestellt so hat es am mir Amira
Mohammed Ali eben erläutert in der
Pressekonferenz beim Fraktionsvorstand
und darüber müsste die gesamte Fraktion
jetzt abstimmen ich bin ein bisschen
skeptisch ob dieser Plan aufgeht auch
wenn man dadurch möglicherweise die
Arbeitsplätze von MitarbeiterInnen und
Mitarbeiterinen der Fraktion Mitarbeiter
in der Fraktion ein wenig länger halten
kann aber ob sich die Partei ob sich die
Fraktion da darauf einlässt ist die
große Frage also unterm Strich aus
meiner Sicht heute hier doch mehr Fragen
als Antworten in dieser Pressekonferenz
die großes Interesse hatte bei den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und ja
vielleicht können wir den einen und
anderen Punkt noch mal erläutern und
hinterfragen Kollege Bauer das machen
wir sehr sehr gerne Herr Schaffer also
das war ja schon interessant etwa eine
Stunde jetzt diese Pressekonferenz sogar
ein bisschen länger gab viele Nachfragen
und auf die eine oder andere Frage dann
doch nicht so die kllar Antwort also das
Prozedere haben sie ja beschrieben we
bleiben wir vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz beim Prozedere also offenbar Z
Abgeordnete des Bundestages der
Linksfraktion sind heute morgen
ausgetreten wenn wir mir Muhammed Ali
glauben dann wäre ja stand jetzt der
Fraktionsstatus dahin das heißt also sie
haben eben das ja schon gesagt aber doch
gerne noch mal die Rückfrage wenn die
linke das nicht dem nicht zustimmt dass
die in der Fraktion blieben dann wäre
eben auch der Fraktion Status dahin und
damit würde dann was damit
zusammenhängen aus ihrer
Sicht das müssen wir jetzt mal schauen
also wichtig dass wir diese
Unterscheidung noch mal klar machen ne
die sie eben in Ihrer Frage auch mit
drin hatten die sind aus der Partei
ausgetreten und ob es vielleicht 11 oder
12 noch werden das muss man dann mal
sehen das ist ja die maximale Zahl die
in den vergangenen Tagen auch immer
wieder gehandelt worden ist dass bis zu
11 oder 12 die Partei dann verlassen
könnten ob sich die Fraktion darauf
Einlässen dass diese im Moment z oder
neun ähm in der Fraktion bleiben können
das wird sich weisen in den nächsten
Tagen wenn Sie
wenn die Partei das nicht mitspielt äh
was ich durchaus verstehen kann ähm weil
sie da auch wieder getrieben wird von
einer Minderheit hier in diesem Fall
also wenn die Fraktion das nicht
mitspielt dann verliert die Fraktion
viele Privilegien die sie als Fraktion
jetzt hat sie verliert finanzielle
Unterstützung durch den Bundestag sie
verliert ihren Fraktionsstatus sie
verliert dann eben auch den die
Fraktionsvorsitzenden sie kann viele
parlamentarische Dinge nicht mehr so
leisten wie im Moment sie kann keine
kleinen oder großen Anfragen mehr
stellen sie wird Verluste bei der
Redezeit in Kauf nehmen sie kann keine
aktuelle Stunde beantragen wodurch die
Linke in den vergangenen Jahren ja immer
wieder aufgefallen ist dass sie nämlich
sozialpolitische Themen über eine
Aktuelle Stunde dann immer noch mal
zusätzlich ins Parlament gebracht hat
all das würde wegfallen es würde wie
gesagt jede Menge Personal auch fehlen
und Personal braucht man um politisch zu
arbeiten auch im Bundestag auch als
Gruppe dann okay und dann gucken wir auf
den Inhalt was haben wir jetzt gelernt
was dieser Verein bisher und diese
Partei ab Januar denn dann inhaltlich
leisten soll und das muss sich ja dann
doch auch deutlich unterscheiden von dem
was die Linkspartei zumindest nach Sicht
von Frau Wagenknecht bisher
leistet ja guter Punkt da werden wir
sicher den den nächsten Tagen auch noch
mal genauer drauf gucken ich habe
anfangs vor dieser Pressekonferenz schon
erwähnt dieses fünfseitige wie Sarah
Wagenknecht es nennt Manifest erwähnt
fünf Seiten mit den vier Punkten etwas
weiter beschrieben zu den Themen
wirtschaftliche Stabilität soziale
Gerechtigkeit Frieden und Freiheit also
da sind viele Punkte drin die kann
wahrscheinlich jeder unterschreiben wie
das aber dann im Detail ausfällt das
wird man sich genauer angucken müssen
und da wird man auch noch mal von den
die diese neue Partei gründen Willen
noch mal genauer nachfragen müssen wie
sie sich denn den einen und anderen
Punkt vorstellen wir haben es ja hier
beispielsweise bei der Migrationspolitik
aber auch bei der Europapolitik deutlich
an den Nachfragen gehört von den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier in der
Bundespressekonferenz also da ist noch
alles noch nicht längst alles besprochen
und noch längst nicht alles aufgeklärt
der Verein das haben wir gelernt der
will nicht Mitglieder sammeln sondern
der will Geld sammeln um diese Partei
dann
oder um das Geld zu haben was man für
eine Parteigründung braucht ich hab es
eingangs schon gesagt es wird sehr viel
organisatorische Arbeit nötig sein um
diese Landesverbände aufzubauen es wird
Personal brauchen die dann diese
Landesverbände betreuen und organisieren
also da kommt eine Menge zusammen und
wenn man sich anguckt die letzte größere
Aktion von Sarah Wagenknecht war das
Projekt Aufstehen
1819 auch da hätte es sehr viel
Organisation gebraucht aber dieses
Projekt Aufstehen ist dann
schlussendlich an der Organisation
gescheitert
und deswegen müssen man sehr genau
beobachten ob das jetzt in diesem
konkreten Fall hier in diesem neuen
Anlauf eines parteipolitischen Projekts
ob das diesmal Sarah Wagenknecht besser
gelingt und ob sie mehr und
hartnäckigere Mitstreiter hat und Herr
Scherer zum Abschluss vielleicht
nur noch kurz da werden wir um 12 Uhr
auch noch mal mehr Zeit haben noch mal
drüber zu sprechen aber um 13 Uhr ist
der Martin schirdewann von der Linken ja
zur Pressekonferenz da sind wir dann
auch hier live bei Phöenix natürlich
live dabei was bedeutet das was wir
bisher zumindest gehört haben aus ihrer
Sicht als erster Eindruck für die
Linkspartei das kommt drauf an welchen
Winkel man welchen Blickwinkel man da
anlegt auf der einen Seite kann es
natürlich sein wenn es diese
Parteigründung denn tatsächlich mal gibt
und wenn diese Partei dann auch
tatsächlich bei den Wahlen antritt bei
denen sie antreten möchte könnte das
natürlich durchaus an Wähler die die
Linke auch Wählerstimmen kosten auf der
anderen Seite könnte es aber auch sein
dass die Linke sich bekrabbelt dass sie
jetzt wieder freier agieren kann ohne
eine in den eigenen Reihen die die
eigene Politik und die
Mehrheitsentscheidung von Parteitagen
beispielsweise ständig kontrakariert und
als Minderheit das was eine Mehrheit von
dieser Partei in dieser Partei gewollt
hat immer wieder in Frage gestellt hat
also könnte möglicherweise im Idealfall
aus Sicht der Linken könnten sie sich
viel besser und klarer positionieren als
das in den vergangenen Monaten der Fall
gewesen ist und das ist noch ein
wichtiger Punkt wie ich finde Sarah
Wagenknecht hat eben die Verantwortung
für die Wahlniederlagen und die
schlechten Wahlergebnisse der Linken in
den vergangenen Monaten ausschließlich
auf die Programmatik der Partei gelenkt
bzw geschoben irgendwie sie hat dabei
überhaupt nicht erwähnt dass der Disput
den es seit Monaten wenn ich gar seit
ein zwei Jahren gibt zwischen ihr und
der Mehrheit der Partei möglicherweise
mutmaßlich auch dazu beigetragen hat
dass die Linke bei Wahlen so schlecht
abgeschnitten hat zuletzt und es nicht
ausschließlich an der Programmatik und
den politischen Zielen der Partei
gelegen hat er scherfer darüber werden
wir auf jeden Fall im Laufe dieses Tages
noch mal sprechen vielen dank Ihnen für
die ersten Einschätzungen direkt nach
dieser Pressekonferenz live aus Berlin
danke und da meine Damen und Herren
sehen wir uns auf jeden Fall wieder um
12 Uhr werden da drauf noch mal schauen
und natürlich auch auf den Krieg in
narost um 13 Uhr dann schon mal
angekündigt die Pressekonferenz